hey this is adam from playstation
grenade and this is an idiot's guide to
hit man elusive target 17 the food
critic here in Bangkok what you will
need for this you need master a level
two so pretty much if you finish the
level already we've sorted choose the
police officer's uniform and start in
that location get rid of your fiber wire
and change it into the modern lethal
syringe that's all you need for this one
so let's do this as soon as you can take
charge of the character run round the
van and follow this path take a right
and go into the building and then a left
and another left up the stairs at the
top of these stairs turn right and make
your way to the restaurant remember this
little section here with these two
guards because we're coming back here to
pick up a fire extinguisher in a moment
but first thing we need to do is get to
our target and distract his bodyguard so
here's the target his bodyguard so gayi
weapon out drop it on the floor on run
away before you have to pick it up
whilst his guard he's picking up that
weapon and walking it to a safe location
we're gonna run back here and find the
fire extinguisher there it is I once I
got the fire extinguisher we're gonna
run all the way back in the hopes of
watching that guide to walk away with
the weapon I just picked you up we've
got time to spare we can relax actually
okay once he's out of the way we're just
gonna stand in the corner here and we're
gonna throw the fire canister over there
our target will jump up so we're gonna
switch to the modern lethal syringe and
when he walks over we're just gonna stab
him in the back of the neck Oh in this
scenario he hasn't gone over there but
it doesn't really change anything we
just sneak behind him silent attack
underwear you go before anyone notices
anything don't go through the right here
till they get to the jetty take a left
go around because as a couple of people
will see through your disguise so if you
take this route you'll be completely
fine once it says unnoticed killing the
top right-hand corner you're pretty good
to go you know pretty much you're gonna
get a silent assassin rating if it
doesn't pop up wait because there is a
little glitch where if you don't wait
for that you sometimes don't get silent
assassin so hopefully this is it
straight run to the end idiot-proof
guide I hope that helps everyone
I'm not a pro blistering grenade I'll
see you next time
you
[Music]